تطير بركابها بلا اجنحه ولا سماء ليست
بصاروخ ولا طائره النفاثه لكن سرعتها تفوق
سرعه الصوت كبسوله صغيره داخل انبوب
تنقلكم من دبي الى الرياض خلال خمس
واربعين دقيقه فقط ويمكنها عبور قاره
باكملها في غضون ساعات قليله انها تقنيه
هايبرلوب
قبل عشر سنوات خرج الملياردير الامريكي
ايلون ماسك متحدثا عن تقنيه جديده في عالم
المواصلات والنقل قال حينها انه سئم من
الازدحام المروري كانت فكرته تتمحور حول
ربط سان فرانسيسكو بيلوس في رحله تستغرق
نصف ساعه فقط والحديث كان عن تقنيه
هايبرلوب التقنيه التي ستقلب معايير السفر
والتنقل
يتكون هايبر لوك بشكل رئيسي من انبوب
وكبسولات والفكره تقوم على حركه الكبسولات
داخل الانبوب دون اي احتكاك حتى مع الهوى
لذلك يعمل هايبر لوب على الحركه داخل نظام
ضغط منخفض خال من الهواء في الانابيب
المدمجه مع بعضها حيث يتم تفريغها من
الهواء بشكل كامل كما انه صديق للبيئه اذ
لا يستخدم في تشغيله الوقود ولا يطلق ايا
بعثات كربونيه
الكبسولات تسير على وساده هوائيه مضغوطه
ولا تلامس جدران الانابيب من خلال مجال
المغناطيسي يتم توليده بمحرك كهربائي
يعتمد على الطاقه الشمسيه بتلك الاليه
تصبح للكبسولات سرعه عاليه جدا تصل الى
1200 كيلو متر في الساعه اي تقريبا بسرعه
الصوت وكل كبسوله تستطيع حمل ما بين 20
و30 راكبا ويمكن ان يرسل في الانبوب نفسه
عده كبسولات بفارق 30
ثانيه فقط دون خطر حدوث تصادم بينها او
انحرافها عن مسارها مع وجود مسافه امان
بين الكبسولات
شركات عالميه عده تعمل على تطوير تقنيه
هايبر لوب وبعضها لديها مشاريع يتم العمل
عليها حاليا في السعوديه والامارات
والولايات المتحده ودول اخرى وعدد كبير من
الرحلات التجريبيه تم اجراؤها بنجاح من
فوائد اطلاق الشبكات هايبرلو سهوله الوصول
الى المراكز الحضاريه وتمكن الذين يعيشون
في مناطق نائيه من الوصول الى وظائفهم
بسلاسه اكبر وقد يسهم هايبر لوب ايضا في
حل ازمات الاسكان التي تواجه المدن الكبرى
في جميع انحاء العالم كما انه يراعي
البيئه واقل كلفه وهادئ جدا بحسب الشركات
المطوره هايبر لوب اكفا من السفر الجوي في
استخدام الطاقه بست مرات واسرعوا بثلاث
مرات من اسرع قطار في العالم ورغم ان
دخوله الفعلي في الخدمه قد يستغرق بضع
سنوات اخرى الا انه حتما سينقل العالم
مفهوم جديد للسفر والنقل السريع